a portrait of the English singer Adele
and fish and chips and ketchup Welsh
singer Tom Jones created using old
cassette tapes
and X Spice Girl Mel C all in glitter
Welsh artist Nathan why burn has given
pop art a 21st century revival pop out
to me I guess is just about popular
culture things that happening in the
media right now things with celebrities
or celebrity scandals or it could be the
death of a celebrity kind of in a very
anti warholian way I guess I kind of
document things as they happen in the
artist works with unusual things like
chocolate and ketchup he used make up
for his portrait of the late British
singer David Bowie in character as Ziggy
Stardust
you
when selecting the material to make the
porter at the celebrity out of it
usually has some sort of relation to
them whether it's something they're
comically known for or a stereotype or
something as simple as their surname so
it could be keith lemon made lemon it
could be something like Donald Trump
with Mexican food because of the humor
and the irony of it so it the relation
is always there whether it's comical or
conceptual the material is not the only
unusual aspect of Y burns works he used
his feet to create his portrait of
soccer star Cristiano Ronaldo and his
tongue to paint the singer Miley Cyrus a
Justin Bieber song inspired him to use
lipstick to depict the teen heartthrob
baby if you like the way the YouTube
video of how the portrait was created
has attracted millions of clicks I just
thought it'd be quite cool because this
song called love yourself was really big
at the time valentine's day was coming
up and he's got a lot of big huge mostly
female fans so I thought it'd be quite
cool just to give them something that
they could look at and think oh I wish I
did that or I wish I could own that so I
thought I'd make a portrait just amusing
kisses Nathan why burn studied art in
Cardiff he's always been fascinated by
Welsh culture and has made portraits of
poet Dylan Thomas and singer Shirley
Bassey who was born in Cardiff
but he's interested in the role of
celebrity in today's consumer society as
a whole and the universality of art I
quite like the fact that my artwork
speaks to everybody you could either see
it as this huge concept where I'm using
these commercial products to relate to
celebrities and commercialization and
loads a different sort of Andy Warhol
like theories like that and I've
displayed in things like galleries and
museums but I've also exhibited in
restaurants and corner pubs in the
street absolutely anyway like at the
educational science center in Cardiff he
used over 4,500 Smarties to make a huge
portrait of the Nobel prize-winning
physicist Albert Einstein a great
success with visitors
we get people stopping on the stairs
midway up and going look at that isn't
it amazing um it's been really really
well received not just by the staff but
by all the visitors you can tell exactly
who it is straightaway and then when
they get closer and they read about it
and they see the smarties the Smarties
the Einstein thing just connects like
good science project should say yes
because I'm very very well indeed he
finds his inspiration for new projects
everywhere like in the city shopping
centers and he doesn't need to go buy
special art supplies I've just been
shuffling and I got a bit of coffee
which works very well to work with about
chocolate baked beans campbell soup
which would work great for an andy
warhol portrait so absolutely anywhere
inspiration to come from and as long as
it relates to the person imix great
portrait why burn is working on a
portrait of this greatest Idol American
artist Andy Warhol who launched pop art
with his paintings of Campbell's soup
cans his choice of material soup of
course
the texture of the card ball soup is
it's a lot thicker than some of the
other soups and sauces that I've worked
with so is this proven to be a little
bit different but the color is great it
definitely looks extremely foodie so I'm
really pleased with with how it's
working so far Nathan why burn a
talented artist who is recreating pop
art in the 21st century with food
instead of paint
you